ok say hello welcome another
daily press appointment online
and live on ubs
today is friday november 27 at
marshan stadium date represents my
tweets follows a song sebastian coates from
videoconference president says i
would love to  or agricultural strategy
vaccine vaccination games covin nineteen
one of the points in 10 matches then
allow me to start with
the presidency's agenda for next week
monday morning president sandrine will
give a speech at the schengen forum
by video conference tuesday morning the
president will speak  at the plenary of
the conference of specialized bodies
for
kozak community affairs via video conference later in
the morning she will deliver a speech at
the conference dedicated to the
european day of people with disabilities at
level via video conference again on tuesday
she will give a speech at the summit
digital organized by
mr peter altmaier the minister
german economy and energy by
videoconference again on
tuesday afternoon the president
will first deliver a speech at a
seminar dedicated to the
european health union organized by the s&d group of
the european parliament also by
videoconference  then she will speak at the
european health summit
obviously again by videoconference
on the other hand on Wednesday she will chair
the college meeting physically as always
the president ended in
hatred will also speak at
the lisbon web summit on Wednesday which takes
place virtually
this year she  joins nine
college members who will take part in
discussions on the future of the
global tech industry they will take part
in roundtables are press events
various European policies aimed at
shaping our digital future and
affirming our goal of becoming
a global digital leader  we will
share with you more details
about their partici  ipation early
next week on
thursday the president will meet
mr alexandre danset ferrin president of
the union of european
football associations uefa
she will also meet mrs odile
renault basso president of the
european bank for reconstruction and
development
later in the day the president
will address the general assembly of
the association and its 1000 united on a
generation inc axis
and finally on Friday the president will
meet Mrs. anne trees and beach
prime minister of serbia by
videoconference all denounce the
new commission maria gabriela
research and without you ready  to take
you exciting a vast tote
thomas méline on skis skis and ska
vaccinates this site
five matches five matches except in cannes
says we train presidents enjoyable
our minister who that's where you live
position to ben ali's ministers in one
tax increase of hornos specific
contact phoneix week of state of play
for the moment in juneau is in crisis
said they would take effect the indices
[Music]
mister big thing to deal with family the
insider pin like so we believe in focus
everything said in plant protection and 28 and
that our possibilities that make us
endorse xiu prison and which will take effect
in say nicolas no sorry i see that
nicolas that your question is on
something else
so we will come back to you
later david yes yes thank you eric
barrel of oil
céline obviously it is on the budget
next generation ue is this  that there is a
plan b that the commission wants or
could propose thank you plan b it is
provided for by the treaty if there is no
multi-annual financial framework which is
in place the treaty provides for it as you
know it as we  we have already explained
here on many occasions what is
happening from a budgetary point of view and
of course the services of the
commission are working
from a technical point of view on all
the alternatives but our priority is  st
and remains to be able to implement
both the multi annual financial framework
that does not expire wish i knew as
soon as possible and from the beginning of
next year are there any further
questions on this subject for us
today i  I don't see any and so
I'm opening the debate to other subjects and
I'm giving the floor to nicolas yes hello
[Music]
I'm going to put the camera like that you
see no hello hello I had a
question I think that  it's for
commissioner bourrel's team
concerning libya erinyes i wanted to
know where we are with our
turkish friends after the summons of the
european and italian ambassadors
also the various declarations in
ankara in fact denying any legitimacy
to the irigny operation  in particular because
it did not ask permission
from turkey and from
and from and from nato and therefore I wanted to
know if on your side there was any
follow-up on this affair of
turkey's refusal of  boarding of a
ship t  urc by a German frigate
thank you nicolas I believe that the game has a
life with statements from elsewhere
on this subject but I pass the floor to
people
thank you it was a statement on Tuesday
where we explained the events
our position on the operation  irigny
on the mandates of operation ireny
on inspection 1 on the events there
last sunday the position of the union
it is very clear we also have to
express its position and explain its
position in the summons of our
ambassador to ankara  and the follow up the
actions followed are as always
if operation ireny does something
in the area of 100 operations we will send
report to the united nation at the panel
of experts and it is the practice our n
rmal tactic that they  have done
always smiling on the actions
of operations cured in the area of
eration on the interventions on the i
spections and on the east on the searc
es for a stick nicolas you are a fan s
op yes o
i quite i i i wanted i
wanted to know the inspection did not come to
life the time
of ship embargo violation items do
the ship inspection
was the whole ship searched
so can we say 100%
that there are no disturbing elements
or is it only on the
partial search of the ship that you
pronounce on the fact that there is no  there
was no violent element the embargo
here you allow it like that avoids
speaking again after I
just wanted there was I think a meeting
between the ambassador of place in libya and
the ministers of the interior and a half
libyan foreign affairs
also on the operation and annie i think
in general on immigration security issues
if you had a point on that and if i
may on the budget n 10 6 on the
external relations budget for the  next period
apparently it's blocking do you
have hope that we'll be able to
unblock  uer where can you tell us
a word about the essential point
or the point that you think is
essential to unblock the situation
on this subject there excuse me for having been
quite long but like that I kill
three birds with one stone
thank you three points on the first point
we have already explained that in the
declaration that until the moment of
the interruption of the inspection did not
find any illegal material but we
could not finish with
the inspection  because turkey
interrupted inspection the second time
on the specific meeting i don't have
any information there the contact of our
ambassador on the spot are
daily things so i'm not sure if
we distributed information
on each one  meeting the ambassador
is not a habit here but in
general we are in regular contact
with our Libyan partners to
naturally explain the modus
operandi of ireny operations and also
their other thing  because our
commitment with libya is something
that liu has on a daily basis have me
on the third on the third point
indicates is I think that if it rains for
a pure explained thank you we keep
this question  and we will return to the
question of the budget to indicate insofar
as there are specific comments to
be made on the budget of a
particular program until the more general question
of the multiannual financial framework
has not been resolved anna me  says
that he will come back to you bilaterally
on this issue we will look at it
will come back to you nicolas sol remained
in exchange he was from any supplier
in practice the goods christian you have
a question about the operation is
over libya it's  for me I missed a name
was brought you have to be careful
christian yes it's just to turn
a little question for computer
it's not the first time that he
actually says that irigny documents
all the operations of  control
some she carried out she transmits
to the united nations to the panel of experts
just to know what they
can decide and when can they
decide something since
indeed irigny to a mandate of
the security council and second small
precision the boat that was boarded on
Sunday is a container ship a
container ship is huge
I imagine that the ships of operation
irigny do not pick up like
customs officers but that often they are
informed upstream to  carrying out an
intervention like this is what we
can reasonably deduce that
nothing illegal was found,
but that does not mean that there was
nothing illegal on board and that we did not  been able to
demonstrate this because the search
is interrupted thank you thank you it's not
for me me were speculating on the deaf
on the second on the second aspect
of the question
the first question this more for the
united nation because the operations of  e
ii y reign are in our world
confidential is also the transmission
of reports on the incident on the
inspections are also confidential
it is a report to the sessions their
report for the panel of experts of the
united nations and the follow up it is for
the united nations because the
operations of the operations would say at the level
of the irini mission are mandated by
the european union based on the resolutions
of the united nations security council
to stop the deliveries of weapons to
libya so we are doing our park
if we find out  something if we
have doubts if we have any
observations we share all the
elements with a spanish expert
from the united nations
thank you
let's stay on external affairs and do
you have a question hello
everyone thank you
this possibility me I have the question  to
nabila concerning ethiopia and
skilful skins and there we provide service
7 days a week and 6 nabila was not there
we will find someone  another to
answer you
asia represents european funds
continuously and invests a support structure
limited to my rest pebble beach on mac
queen is what you been graduation it's
soon in day one action to prevent the
ongoing as l  'italy crisis in ti
bridge n 1 to prevent dress our kids
it's too late
defeated anna nabila thank you and i
function and a half at the custom search
selection of in the states is and return to
politics 'solution' or others we se
door
given to do you snows and everything african
union was born je te oui au ta de paris
18 110 systems inc a release of call
you know that we have been and
specialties is delighted and has been very
vocal petit albino loic swiny active and
rich fit  at tola vologe and admit
of small business prime minister
for innerhofer master of trades mekonnen
said at home sweet minister habib and
prime minister of sudan nsrs capacity
chance person of igad yes oh so and talk
with but this land moussa faki di  t
africanews other characters from the
africans yun junghee au so we are
having and women x mini clip from get him
to live and boys at the point
flesh straws of the african a fall open door
ford at the top level head world
truck ends  of destabilization
asus is will josh man and john
humanitarian in crisis in ethiopia of
claude fidji us mobilizing additional
anthill to false refugees driving
sudan of commissions two addresses of
italian riemann crysis or nokia
soaga naouri pitt two massive will
better register a political agent
solution maspie  bland and left
poutine place of reception conditions
facilitated in nîmes small access to people
in need and no transfer offer hostile
it is non-interference except in
day school part of freedom of the media
and respect of international
humanitarian law of sas binard
massachusetts we are going to all
parties cop15 five matches nabila forest
d2 do not condone advanced john thain
at stadium
vere  na said yes in fossils and press
conference to work life implemented on
ovi store request and offer said
commission
we are looking france has in many many
benzekri fixing 10 specific
yes confess this editor martha double
level all kinds you might not in
not be  ok nicolas as we are close to
the weekend want to know
to come back to the question of ski ch
and ski resorts is there
a european commission plan to
make snow fall on
ski resorts
what i  I have heard all this debate which
for the moment seems theoretical
to me to give an idea I am
still in the mountains or above
below 2000 meters there is not a gram
of snow today and there is
no announcement for the coming days
so I wanted to know if you had a
plan on the on them on the comet on this
subject thank you nicolas I was wondering
if what is behind you on the wall
are ski poles or
skis by the way more  general and
I think I just got the answer
is
given the loads you are carrying I
thought you were at altitude
as you know we don't have we
have plans to try to
fight climate change
those plans  are very well known I
am not going to ask Viviane to go up
on the podium to explain them to you in
detail you will find all the
necessary documentation but you make a
point which seems essential to me is that
we often do here in the
press room and that the  Commissioners
often do is that there is a
very close link between our policies to
combat climate change
and the economic
prospects for the European economy
and for the global economy in general
and  trying to dissociate the two is a
completely artificial exercise and
that is why we are trying to
link together all the elements of our
economic policy of our
climate policy you s  But in the
European semester, for example, there are now
very many references to the
sustainable development goals I don't
know how to say the French to the
sustainable development goals,
that's it, but it all came back to me and all this
indeed and winger so I wish
for you  if it's snowing
this weekend if you had planned to go
skiing here is and if not a good little
Savoyard dish or I don't know where you have it
can be compensated there are
there other questions for us  today
it is not the case so thank you for your
attention and see you Monday